I missed I think what's the coolest
property a pass was for you tell me I
know it's not the whole triangle
obviously but it's enough to see the pan
how it prime numbers are there in
Pascal's right
no seriously look at how many prime
numbers are there is one a prime number
two's prey threes plant sevens prime v
xi prime I know this symmetry so of
course you get them over here where are
the rest of the primes what about in
here are you telling me there are no
pines in here I can't there's the first
number one not for one there are no
clouds in here but that's not the real
mind blow
watch watch have a look at those rows
which have those prime numbers in them
let's have a look at row number five do
you notice anything unusual about the
numbers or how about row seven it's even
more suspicious now I know row number
eleven you probably don't recognize
these numbers but you can make a pretty
educated guess can't you get this number
one so there are no primes
except for in the Zen plus of course
they have to be prime to you like it's
all good but where you do get a prime in
every road that has a prime all of the
terms are multiples of the prime what is
up with that have a good recess everyone